>> ON WEDNESDAY YOU RECEIVED THE
FIRST EVER PRESIDENTIAL ALERT.
>> PRESIDENTIAL ALERT?
>> THIS SYSTEM WAS THE RESULT OF
YEARS OF CAREFUL PLANNING FOR
USE ONLY IN CASES OF NATIONAL
EMERGENCIES.
>> FAILING "NEW YORK TIMES" SAYS
I CHEATED ON TAXES.
DUH, IT'S CALLED BEING SMART.
WHAT IS THIS?
>> FINALLY, A SYSTEM FOR
REACHING ALL AMERICANS WHEN IT
COUNTS MOST.
>> ALERT, PUERTO RICO IS FINE
NOW?
I GUESS THE PAPER TOWELS WORKED?
>> EVERY PRESIDENT SINCE FDR HAS
COMMUNICATED DIRECTLY WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE HAD FIRESIDE CHATS.
AND NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
EMERGENCY ALERTS.
>> ALERT, THE ONLY DIFFERENCE
>> HURRICANE FLORENCE GOT THE
CAROLINAS SO WET I THOUGHT IT
WAS THE PREMIERE OF "MAGIC
MIKE."
>> AND EVEN SOME LESS THAN
EMERGENCIES.
>> SEPTEMBER 11th WAS ALMOST A
MONTH AGO.
IS THAT EVEN INFORMATION?
>> WARNING, WHITE MEN ARE UNDER
ATTACK.
OH, NO.
>> KID ROCK SOUNDS BETTER THAN
EVER?
>> CONGRATS TO GOOD GUY
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
BELIEVE MEN.
>> HI.
>> AMBER ALERT, REMEMBER
TIFFANI AMBER THIESSEN?
THAT'S WHEN WOMEN WERE SLAM
DUNK?
>> I'M NOT GETTING ANY OF THESE
ALERTS ON MY PHONE.
>> YOU'RE NOT?
>> NO.
THANKS, CRICKET WIRELESS.
>> CRICKET WIRELESS, NOW AREN'T
YOU HAPPY WE HAVE AWFUL SERVICE?
JOIN NOW FOR ONLY $2.99 PER
DECADE.
OUR PHONES HAVE CANDY INSIDE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]